good morning Hank it's Tuesday
specifically it is the 320 third
consecutive Tuesday I have made a
vlogbrothers video except for one
Tuesday when I had meningitis and
another Tuesday when I had a
labyrinthitis a disease with a very
metaphorically resonant name but an
extremely low pleasantness factor what
I'm getting at is that I usually upload
these videos on time because I am a
punctual person like I joined conference
calls exactly one minute before the call
was supposed to begin I arrived at the
doctor's office exactly 15 minutes early
in case there's paperwork to fill out
and I must arrive at the airport at
least 90 minutes before my flight is
scheduled to depart and when I say must
I mean must like if I don't there is a
five alarm fire in my brain now there's
this line in the Great Gatsby where Nick
says everyone suspects himself of at
least one of the cardinal virtues and
this is mine I am one of the few honest
people I have ever known and that's nice
Nick that's a nice sentiment but do you
show up at Gatsby's house at the exact
moment the invitation indicated the
party would begin because I would
punctuality is the cardinal virtue I
suspect myself of I might not be calm I
might not be pleasant I might not be
good but I will be on time I also really
like it when other people value
punctuality like rosianna once called
punctuality the most important
commandment on the tablets and I'm not
sure she was kidding she's always two
minutes early two conference calls to me
being punctual is a way of saying to
other people I value your time enough to
show up when we agreed to show up or
even slightly earlier and I think that's
important because ultimately time is all
we have it is overwhelmingly the most
important human resource you know
sometimes you identify so closely with
an ideal that it becomes part of how you
understand yourself like when I think
about Who I am I think I'm a husband I'm
a father and I am a punctual person and
once you get to that point like I don't
just believe punctuality is
unambiguously good I believe it is
inseparable from what constitutes good
it's difficult to listen to voices that
disagree with you let alone take them
seriously right I mean who could be
opposed to punctuality be be white as it
turns out who is best known today as the
author of Charlotte's Web but also was a
brilliant magazine writer and I was
recently reading a collection of his in
which he wrote we teach our child many
things I don't believe in and almost
nothing I do believe in we teach
punctuality particularly if the
enforcement of it disturbs the peace
my father taught me by example that the
greatest defeat in life was to miss a
train only after many years did I learn
that an escaping train carries away with
it nothing vital to my health railroad
trains are such magnificent objects we
commonly mistake them for destiny I've
always defended my punctuality
absolutism by saying it's about
respecting other people and their time
but if I'm yelling at my family to get
in the car so we're not 86 minutes early
for a flight am I really respecting
people and their time or am I just
disturbing the peace now I've never
missed a train or for that matter of
flight but until I read those lines it
had literally never occurred to me that
an escaping train carries with it
nothing vital to my health but it
doesn't of course I still value
punctuality but lately I've been
thinking that as with so many things
extreme punctuality can become a vice
even when what you worship is good and
Noble it doesn't always make you better
or nobler all right I have to go pack
for our Spring Break vacation we fly out
in the morning I'm not gonna miss the
flight or anything but I am gonna try to
be less early Hank I'll see you on
Friday